we're asked to graph this function
finding the roots and the vertex of this
parabola so to find the roots when
people talk about roots they're talking
about the points of intersection of this
function and the x-axis so this is the
x-axis here this is the y-axis and
you're going to intersect the x-axis
when Y is equal to zero so to find the
roots so to find the roots we set Y is
equal to zero so we solve the equation x
squared plus 4x minus 12 is equal to 0
all I did is I said Y is equal to 0 and
then I swap to the left and right hand
sides now to factor this we have a 1 as
a leading coefficient so we don't have
to do the kind of the the all out
grouping we can just think are there two
numbers whose product is negative 12 and
if I add them I get 4 so let's think
about it looks like two positive six and
negative two would work if I will go
through all of negative 12s factors so
this can be factored as X plus 6 times X
minus 2 6 minus 2 is 4 6 times negative
2 is negative 12 so that's going to be
equal to 0 if we have two numbers and if
when you multiply them we equals 0 that
means that either X plus 6 is equal to 0
or X minus 2 is equal to 0 subtract 6
from both sides of this equation you get
X is equal to negative 6 add 2 to both
sides of this equation and you get X is
equal to 2 so Y is equal to 0 when X is
equal to negative 6 or X is equal to 2
so let's graph both of those points X is
equal to negative six Y will be equal to
0 so X is 1 2 3 4 5 6 so negative 6
comma 0 that will be on the graph of
this function or the graph of this
parabola and also the point X is equal
to 2 X is equal to 2 so 1 2 just like
that X is equal to 2 so this is the
point 2 0 now to find the x value of the
vertex there's actually several ways of
doing it there is a formula that gives
it to you but actually the easiest way
to figure it out is it's actually going
to be the mid
link between the two zeroes if you're
already figured out the zeroes the x
value where the vertex is going to lie
because a April because the the two
zeros are always symmetric around the
axis of symmetry which is the same x
value as the vertex you can just find
the midpoint of these two points and
that will be the x value of the vertex
so let's just do that so if we take the
mid point we can literally just average
these two numbers so negative 6 plus 2
over 2 is negative 4 over 2 which is
equal to negative 2 so the vertex is X
is equal to negative 2
and when X is equal to negative 2 what
is y y so this is X is the vertex and
then Y will be equal to negative 2
squared is positive 4 4 times negative 2
is negative 8 and then we have a minus
12 there so 4 minus 8 gets us to
negative 4 minus another 12 is negative
16 so the point negative 2 negative 16
so the point negative 2 negative 16 is
going to be our vertex so let me graph
that I think it's going to fall off of
this graph a little bit so negative 2
and we're going to go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 so it's going to be
right around here we went off the graph
paper but negative 2 negative 2 negative
2 all the way down to negative 16 so
that right there is the vertex negative
2 negative 16 all the way down here we
could lower the y-axis and so if I were
to graph the parabola it would look
something like this it would look
something like that just like that and
obviously it would keep going now I
figured out the vertex in this problem
just by averaging the x values of the
two roots that gave me the x value of
the axis of symmetry which is this right
here X is equal to negative 2 that's the
axis around which the parabola is
symmetric the other way to figure out
the x value of the vertex is to use the
formula negative B over 2a so X so you
could also the X
value of the vertex is equal to negative
B negative 4 over 2 times a a is 1 so
over 2 which is also going to give you X
is equal to negative 2
now the last way to think to solve for
the vertex is to complete the square is
to complete the square on this parabola
right here so what we can do is we can
rewrite it we could say this is y is
equal to x squared plus 4x I'm going to
put the minus 12 out here and what we
want to do is add and subtract the same
number so I can express this as a
perfect square so if I take 1/2 of 4x or
if I have to take a 1/2 of 4 I get 2 if
I square that I can add a 4 here and
then subtract a 4 and then what that
does is it turns this into it turns that
into X plus 2 squared right x plus 2
squared is x squared plus 4x plus 4
we've seen that multiple times so you
have X plus 2 squared and then you have
the minus 4 minus 12 minus 16 so this is
just another way of writing this exact
same function but when you write it this
way when you write it this way
you see that the lowest point this value
this part of the function right here
that part of the function is always
positive it's a quantity squared the
lowest value that it can be is 0 but
then it can only go up from 0 so the
lowest point the lowest Y value we can
take on is when this value this
expression right here is when this
expression right here is 0 and when that
happens the Y value is negative 16
now what x makes this value 0 well x
equals negative 2 will make this 0 if
you wanted to say X plus 2 is equal to 0
this expression right here's going to be
0 when X plus 2 is equal to 0 subtract 2
from both sides X is equal to negative 2
so that's another way to find the vertex
all of them equally valid